les affrontements entre bandes rivales
en pleine recrudescence dernier fait en
date cette semaine quatre adolescents du
quartier du sanitas à tours
arrêté après le tabassage de deux jeunes
de joué-lès-tours un tabassage filmé et
posté sur internet ces bandes ont-elles
franchi un cap dans la violence comment
y mettre un terme
on en parle avec mon invité ce soir on
sort grégoire du lin bonsoir vous êtes
procureur de la république de tours les
affrontements entre bandes rivales de
plus en plus fréquent de plus en plus
violents de plus en plus glorifié par
leurs auteurs grâce à internet vous
vouliez mettre un stop
vous nous direz dans un instant comment
d'abord qui sont ces adolescents qui
s'affrontent et et pourquoi est ce que
ce sont des guerres de territoires des
affrontements commandes communautaire
c'est plutôt des guerres de territoire
c'est surtout une question de
l'appropriation de quartier ils sont
propriétaires du sanitas propriétaire de
joué-lès-tours ils s'affrontent entre
quartiers pour des motifs absolument
futile là on s'aperçoit que c'est une
bande qui est né en 2005 qui est
originaire d'ussel sanitas qui affronte
une bande originaire en 2005
aquarelle menée en 2005 ou à
joué-lès-tours pour cette bande qui a
donc été tabassé ce jocondien qui avait
donc la figure ensemble dont la vidéo a
été postée sur instagram
alors ces phénomènes ce phénomène de
violences entre bandes rivales il n'est
pas il est pas nouveau mais il est en
hausse ces dernières semaines est ce que
c'est une poussée de fièvre ou est ce
que c'est un phénomène qui s'installe
dans la durée ce que vous ne craignez
c'est un phénomène qui est cyclique et
qui revient chaque année donc ce qu'on a
décidé à tour c'est de mettre en place
un groupe local de traitement de la
délinquance qui permet
de d'identifier les auteurs de ces
exactions sur la voie publique et qui
permet d'interpeller ces personnes et
puis ensuite de les neutraliser
judiciairement alors comment comment
faire justement c'est du renseignement
c'est vous retrouvez souvent les mêmes
qui se bat comme ça se passe alors on a
réuni au parquet un certain nombre
d'acteurs d'abord la direction
départementale de la sécurité publique
le renseignement territoriales mais
également les acteurs de terrain comme
keolis puisqu'ils prennent généralement
le tram pour se rendre entre le sanitas
et joué-lès-tours et on partage du
renseignement on met ensemble tout ce
qu'on a et cela nous permet
effectivement de monter des procédures
judiciaires et ensuite de procéder aux
interpellations comme cette semaine où
quatre jeunes mineurs ont été placés en
garde à vue pendant 48 heures puis
immédiatement déférés au parquet quelle
est la difficulté dans ces dossiers
c'est que ce sont des bandes qui sont
très mobiles avec des éruptions
finalement de base de bagarre d'abord
c'est extrêmement difficile de prévenir
ce phénomène parce que c'est des
éruptions effectivement ils se donnent
rendez vous parfois sur les réseaux
sociaux
quatre personnes contre parfois de
personnes une vingtaine contre deux et
ils n'hésitent pas à s'affronter avec
des bâtons des battes de base-ball voir
des armes de poing
heureusement la semaine dernière c'était
factice et puis de commettre des
violences extrêmement graves et je tiens
à le souligner l'un des jocondien s'est
jeté dans le lac de la bergerie pour
échapper à ses agresseurs tellement ils
avaient peur d'y laisser sa vie est-ce
que c'est limité au sanitas a je voulais
tout est-ce que ça gagne un peu le reste
de la métropole n'en ont pas que ça
gagne effectivement l'ensemble de la
métropole qui dit à des affrontements à
la en ce moment toutes les semaines
entre différents cafter les rives du
cher contre le sanitas tour nord contre
la riche joué-lès-tours contre le
sanitas
il faut effectivement enrayer ce
phénomène et pour l'enrayer il faut
avoir une réponse pénale ferme
quel est le rôle des réseaux sociaux
dans ces bagarres on sait que une
avocate de l'un des jocondien qui a été
tabassé dénonce le fait que y ait une
vidéo justement de ce tabassage qui
étaient postés sur instagram
instagram pour leur refuse de l'enlever
que faire pour faire cesser cette cette
humiliation notamment par réseaux
sociaux alors effectivement il se met en
scène sur les réseaux sociaux et ils
n'attendent qu'une chose c'est de voir
le nombre de likes qu'ils ont eue pour
voir leur popularité
ça nous permet également ses vidéos de
les identifier donc c'est judiciairement
extrêmement intéressant se cache pas il
ne se cache pas la problématique est
effectivement c'est qu'à un moment donné
il faut faire supprimer ces vidéos on a
parfois des résultats positifs avec un
certain nombre de réseaux sociaux
parfois on a plus de mal à faire retirer
ses contenus violant systématiquement au
parquet et à la police on demande à ce
que ces vidéos soit retirée on passe par
une plateforme qui est une plate forme
de signalement qui s'appelle pharos qui
à nanterre qui fait un travail quotidien
auprès de cette plateforme pour essayer
de retirer ce type de contenu en un mot
très rapidement que risque-t-il ccc
bastonneurs professionnel aujourd'hui
alors très clairement ils risquent de se
retrouver très rapidement en prison nous
avons décidé au parquet chaque rixe
chaque auteur identifié sera
systématiquement déféré au parquet en
fonction de la personnalité de
l'individu de la gravité des faits il y
aura une gradation de la réponse pénale
pour des mineurs de 15 ans et on pouvait
pas les placer en prison mais ils ont
été placés sous contrôle judiciaire
interdit de territoire sur la métropole
de tours est placée hors département
pendant un certain nombre de mois s'il
faut on n'hésiterait pas on n'hésitera
pas à prononcer des peines
d'emprisonnement ferme
en tout cas les recueillir devant
tribunal correctionnel zéro tolérance
donc merci beaucoup gloire du l'inde est
revenue ce soir sur notre plateau merci